[Music]
excuse me sir you're naked supposed to
be at my wedding right now I'm sorry I
didn't hear what you said I'm just
trying not to look at your G own
spinning hey people of this you have to
accept the fact that he's not coming he
will be here I managed to get arrested
for what
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm not a streaker I'm just trying to
get to my wedding mom I need your help
I'm freaking out I'm put naked for 20
blocks roads now and I keep repeating
the same power over and over again
good night and public awareness shopping
day can you find some of the trash that
you could make a shirt out of you drunk
so to show you what Oh dance pose think
is old lady gonna like that I think
she'd go kick it there where are you are
you okay I'm coming for you in what
world is she picked you over me this is
what you're bringing to the table now
that woman deserves a great wedding it
just needs to be taken out in the back
oh I'm gonna take it out in the back I
need to borrow you soon I'm not giving
me my suit you're gonna give me the damn
suit Devin just tell us
[Music]